hi I'm Erik Bosse and the movie it has
been out for a little while now and just
when my pants began to dry I decided to
rewatch it and I realized this movie is
full of fascinating Easter eggs subtle
visual and production details that I
missed the first time around I know I'm
never supposed to miss anything but I'm
sorry I had to look away from the screen
for the entire movie I'm gonna run
through and point out the 30 details I
found the most interesting so let's get
started right off the bat in the opening
scene notice the brand name of the wax
bill uses to make Georgie's paper-boat
Gulf wax is the exact same name of the
brand of wax bill uses in Stephen King's
book we also see this kind of attention
to detail with the close-up of the
Jackson and which them street signs this
corner is where all the events take
place in the book and I'll point out
more examples as we go Pennywise is
encounter with Georgie is truly
terrifying and Bill scars guards
performance is amazing specifically
notice his eyes when eyes trained on
Georgie while the other looks out
directly at us this is an effect
director Andres muschietti wanted and
intended to do in post for millions of
dollars but skarsgård said he could
physically pull off this trick he also
said he's an evil clown who lives in
sewers making this all super convenient
scarce guards eyes carry a lot of weight
in this movie notice how after this
scene penny wise never once blinks in
the film so cover your eyes all you want
audience he's always watching also
notice what Georgie says here penny wise
actually throws this back at him later
who's gonna carry this could be
foreshadowing the final battle at the
end of the movie remember when bill uses
the bolt gun to kill its incarnation of
Georgie later as bill walks home from
school he says this fish against his
stutter keeps him from finishing this
tongue twister but this is also from the
book where bill says the whole phrase he
thrusts his fists against the posts and
still insists he sees the ghosts to him
that Amy's at the end of the movie penny
wise actually repeats this complete
phrase the final fu to bill and his
stutter as he retreats down the well
shaft he throws to his
against them when Mike goes to the
butcher shop notice this mural on the
side of the building we get a better
look at it later but this is alluding to
another detail from dairies violent
history in the book in 1929 the
townspeople of Derry rose up and
ambushed the Bradley gang a gang of bank
robbers trying to buy ammo at the time
massacring them in a blaze of gunfire
yeah sure let's commemorate this with a
mural what is this parks interact then
when it appears to Stanley in his
father's office the look of the creepy
flute playing woman from the painting is
an homage to the directors past or film
mama machetes vigil style of Mama
rushing at the camera definitely seems
to have inspired the way Pennywise
charges that bill later on in the next
scene as the boys leave Eddie's house
his mother is watching a TV program
called the Derry children's hour and if
you listen closely you can hear the
hosts say that today's word is clown are
you boys off to in such a rush I can
also hear penny wisest voices Eddie goes
in to kiss his mama on the street now
this becomes increasingly obvious as the
film goes on especially when Henry
Bowers sees penny wise on the show later
but anytime adults in this movie are
watching TV they're watching this kids
show for whatever reason and creepy
audio like this was mixed in then when
Ben hears the others riding their bikes
past a library bill shouts hiyo silver
away this is a reference to the Lone
Ranger the Western hero bill quotes in
the book silver is the name of the lone
Ranger's horse and you can actually see
silver written on the side of Bill's
bike meanwhile inside the library I love
to this creepy detail when Ben flips
through the town's history an old woman
in the background stares directly at him
smiling and each time the camera cuts
back to this angle she appears one step
closer then when Ben turns around to
follow the balloon down stairs this
woman is back looking at the stacks like
normal this woman is another incarnation
of it appearing to Ben at the precise
moment he begins to feel afraid down in
the Barrens notice how Bill is wearing a
green shirt with a logo that says
tracker brothers this is another
reference to the book the tracker
brothers is the dairy shipping company
we're in chapter 2 a grown-up version of
eddy encounters penny wise tracker
Brothers also shows up in King's novel
dream catcher as I'll get to later
pretty much all of Kings works are
connected in a crazy detailed extended
universe negative shirts later Eddy
appears wearing a shirt with this
hiller car on it with a V on the grill
this could be a reference to Christine
the Stephen King story about a killer
Ford Plymouth also rich he wears a free
sister creases was an 80s department
store in Bangor Maine Stephen King's
hometown Priestess also gets referenced
in the book moving on when Patrick dies
in the sewers notice how the red balloon
says I heart Derry this could be a
reference to the character
Adrian Mellon in the book he was a gay
man who was beaten and thrown off a
bridge by homophobes while wearing a hat
that said I heart they're also in the
book Patrick is secretly gay and has a
sexual moment with Henry though that
character detail seems to be left out
from the movie okay next up when the
kids go swimming in the quarry something
brushes up against their foot and bill
says it's a turtle another turtle shows
up later in the form of a Lego figure
made by Georgie these Turtles could be
referencing the turtle from Stephen
King's novel so there is a giant nevolin
deity figure known as the turtle he's
later named michurin and he's from a
dimension called the Mac reversed it
carries the earth atop its shell this is
a little weird but it's a book so you
just kind of go with it this turtle is a
cosmic enemy to the entity known as it
and the boys commune with the turtle to
learn how to defeat it michurin also
shows up in Stephen King's Dark Tower
series but he was left out of the hit
movies so we'll see if he shows up in a
sequel but I just like how they included
all these little turtle details as if
he's kind of watching over them the
scene with the blood exploding out of
Beverly's sink was also from the book
but the way it was shot with the blood
hitting the ceiling and covering the
bathroom was an homage to the original
Nightmare on Elm Street
when Johnny Depp got pulled into his bed
and thrown back up as blood covering the
bedroom later when the boys help clean
up the blood
man pokes his head in to Beverly's room
and sees the Frog Prince that's the
story where the princess kisses the Frog
and turns him into a prince which
foreshadows the end of the movie when
this frog kisses the princess to bring
her back moving on to this scene in the
Town Square on the 4th of July in the
background is this big statue of Paul
Bunyan in the book this statue comes to
life to taught Richie and actually a
Paul Bunyan statue does exist in real
life in Bangor Maine and it has creeped
out all the locals now one of my
favorite details is this clown in the
background now it's this moment that
Richie reveals his fear clowns which is
a change in the book that I'll talk
about a bit but look closely this clown
is being played by Bill skarsgård crazy
right like notice how none of the other
kids on stage interact with them they
probably can't see him because it's
taking the form of a
different clown other than Pennywise
just to screw with Richie and the others
and actually his specific type of clown
wardrobe was a lot of on the serial
child killer John Wayne Gacy who worked
as Pogo the clown yes Gacy and Pennywise
alone are pretty much responsible for
ruining clowns for everyone next
Pennywise jumping out of the projector
is another possible Stephen King
reference to another story of his called
the Sun dog in that a dog jumps out of a
picture and here Pennywise crawls on all
fours and growls at them kind of like a
dog inside the well house Ritchie goes
into this room filled with clown dolls
you know the room that people just have
in their houses I guess in on the floor
there's this little Easter Egg a doll
version of the 1990 Tim Curry Pennywise
also when this Pennywise jumps out of
the casket he says Pete Richie
this is another subtle nod to the book
in order to get Ritchie to shut up with
the jokes Ben comes up with a phrase
beep-beep Richie which becomes a running
joke they don't say it in the movie but
here Pennywise is using they'd been
messed with his head and before I
mentioned the other Richie changed with
his fear now in the book the losers
watched the movie I was a teenage
werewolf which leaves Richie with the
fear of werewolves in the text and in
the 1990 miniseries it takes the form of
a werewolf along with other Hollywood
movie monsters and although we don't
really see that in this movie this shot
of Pennywise his hand as werewolf claws
split out of it definitely seems like a
nod to that part of the book and later
in the sewers it briefly takes the form
of another Hollywood movie monster a
mummy as it attacks Ben when they come
back to the house later Richie picks up
and smashes this empty beer bottle check
out the label Bob Grey's
now in the book penny wise has gone
under several aliases over the years one
of whom is Bob gray and I guess he's in
a microbrewery meanwhile down in the
sewer penny wise hypnotizes Beverly by
having her look down its throat these
three lights that we see are further
explained in the book they're called the
dead light these are the actual true
form of the entity known as it and
they're supposed to kill anyone who lays
eyes on them though in the movie they
only hypnotize Beverly now during this
final battle with penny wise notice how
at one point his arms transform into
giant pointy claws now this could be a
reference to its final form in the later
adult part of the book as a giant spider
so these claws could be a tease for what
we'll see in chapter 2 of the movie and
speaking of sequel predictions there's
one final interesting detail in this
closing scene but it involves some major
events that happen to these characters
so skip to this time
if you haven't read the book and you
want to stay completely unspoiled okay
after the losers make their blood oath
and vow to return to Derry if the
monster ever returns pay close attention
to the order in which the characters
leave Stanley leaves first then followed
by Eddie this is foreshadowing the order
of these characters deaths as adults in
the book Stanley takes his own life when
he realizes it has returned and then
Eddie rejoins the other losers in Derry
and their mission to kill it but he gets
killed during the battle with monsters
the editing here even kind of implies
this death connection notice how they
cross dissolve makes it look like
Stanley is fading away as he departs
back this may be the last time any of
these kids see Stanley and finally a lot
of people have said that comedian John
Oliver made a cameo in this movie as
someone seen in the town's diner maybe
but honestly I couldn't find him there's
no scenes in this movie to take place in
a diner or near one and I scan all the
white shots at the Derry streets and the
windows but no luck so let me know if
you spot them do you think it would have
benefited for more detail from the
novel's mythology like the turtle the
Mack reverse the dead lights personally
I love this film for what it was and I
was just happy the movie paid tribute to
Stephen King's universe of details in
these subtle ways but I want to turn it
over to you comment down below with your
thoughts on these connections to the
book or tweet me at Ieva or follow new
rockstars on twitter at new rockstars
for updates on our videos you can also
connect with us through Stardust posting
your reaction and tagging at new
rockstars so we can feature you on our
weekly show than need to know download
the Stardust app by clicking on the link
below and check out our feed for an
additional bonus Easter egg in it that I
didn't get to like and share this video
and subscribe to new rockstars for deep
dives and all the movies you love and if
you really like us you can contribute to
us on patreon big thanks to all of our
donors especially Kelly hopper happy
Halloween everyone hope this video gave
you a spooky scare and thanks for
watching wait a minute